let me ask you
a ridiculously big and the most
important question what's the meaning of
this whole thing
of life well i got a story for that
does this have something to do with the
farm well no no no it's from japan i
used to live in japan i live in osaka
right next to
tanamba beautiful area it's like if
you're gonna live anywhere in japan live
in osaka and you live anywhere in osaka
live next to the restaurant district at
four o'clock in the morning and get good
ramen these are the things in life that
make you who you are
um so there was a shogun and you know he
was
kind of a badass he was really good
killing people really good at running
his empire and then he got a bit
disgruntled in his late 40s and
he said you know i'm just going to give
it all to my son and i'm going to wander
around japan
until i find the perfect cherry blossom
that's what i'm going to do
everybody thought he went crazy he said
no no no that's what i'm going to do he
took his whole entourage with him and so
his son is now the shogun and then he's
just wandering
throughout japan and having all these
incredible crazy adventures as he's
wandering throughout japan you know
fighting abandons and
loving beautiful women and so forth and
then 30 years later um
he's passing these two geisha gals and
one of them turns around and they notice
them slumped over next to a cherry tree
and so she goes over to try to rouse
them and he's dead
and in his hands it's a wilted cherry
blossom
so that's a very japanese story right
the point is that
it's not the actual cer blossom finding
the perfection that matters it's the
it's the things you do on a day-to-day
basis the places you go the people you
meet the experiences you have and the
joy you take in the things that you do
here in the moment now you have to get
there
you know if you look at jiro dreams of
sushi there's this guy 70 years of his
life making the same damn piece of sushi
again and again and again he's the
happiest guy around
albert camus and his story of sisyphus
you know sisyphus should be miserable
it's the greek curse
no he's happy he has total clarity of
purpose
and every day he gets to basically roll
that stone just a little bit better than
the day before a different way than the
day before
and it's not the destination it isn't
getting the stone up to the top of the
hill that matters
it's the fact that the act you find that
joy and that act that ichikai that way
of life that purpose of life
that i think is the closest thing a
human can get to a meaning
you're a blip you know you you didn't
exist
you're dead and if you compare it to the
size of the universe and that time it's
just a little blip
so all you can do with what you have is
just find meaning in the things that you
do on a daily basis and you can't
predict the macro
we have all this wealth and power in
america what if a world war breaks out
we could be destitute like walmart
germany and so
you know you could be a big guy you
could be now living on the street side
would you be miserable
the point of life is getting to a point
that no matter what comes your way what
misfortune comes your way
you're in a position where you can find
a modicum of happiness
and love and empathy for others in that
moment
and then the highest pursuit of life is
the ability to share that mindset
with other people and give it to them
somehow and that's
that's really hard you know because
everybody comes to you they're always
eor
oh doom and gloom and cynical yeah but
this and that and reputation this
you have to somehow transcend all of it
and say you know that doesn't matter
look at the cherry blossoms aren't they
beautiful today and let's find a better
one tomorrow
see the you're also a fan of fishing
i've read somewhere yeah
and one of my favorite books is old man
in the sea
uh where there's an old man
sort of battling a big fish and
uh basically closing out the last
chapter of his life in this battle
so i think another aspect of life with
this boulder
it feels like the boulder gets bigger
and bigger as we get closer to
to uh to death and you know you you find
yourself married to a particular
struggle
uh in life that eventually just kind of
um overtakes the entirety of meaning of
your existence
is do you think uh i know what it is for
me uh do you have something like that
the broader vision that unites your work
with cardano and everything you've done
in life
the the big fish that you're going to
end up
in uh in the dark of night struggling
with in the end
the last chapter of your life like the
big problem you're taking on
in mathematics it was the goldbach
conjecture i'd like to prove that
that's probably not that's a really big
fish uh so do you still have a love for
mathematics oh god yeah of course i do
um you never lose that you never lose it
you lose the ability to do
deep work and you don't have the
creativity and the the raw inspiration
this is why i've gotten to automated
theory improving because what i lack in
because i'm getting older i can now have
computers understand it and use ai to
just solve this stuff it's like the
cheat codes for math
you know so [ __ ] those guys we'll still
do that
but you know mathematics still has those
those last passions and you know there's
all kinds of cool things that i'd like
to see done
the quota complexes allow you to unify
topology and number theory in really
novel ways and they're all kinds of cool
things but who cares
um it's it's
everybody has those those white whales
another thing i'd love to do is bring
back the willie mammoth
you know that's george church's you know
hidden pleasure in five to ten years
it's actually gonna happen and i have
this beautiful ranch in wyoming and i
got to find a way to convince george to
let me raise his his clone mammoth fence
on my among the bison among the bison
they'd probably get along really well
and then i have to learn all these cool
things about willie mammoth like you
know do you shave him in the summer time
and let them get shaggy during the
winter or do you just let that coke go
and then fall
who knows it's an undiscovered country i
just had
i just had the image of charles hoskins
alone on a bison farm
trying to raise a willie mammoth and uh
just start wearing a white suit and say
welcome to hoskins ranch
i'll have a cane with amber on it yeah
yeah the chalkboard that you keep
scrambling on like uh
after the beautiful mind the movie and
you have voices oh the schizophrenia has
already come you guys are all figments
of my imagination anyway
now one of my goals though you know i
love catfish and they live a long time
they get really damn big if you see
those guys
i'd love to catch one now and be in my
60s and catch the same fish twice
and recognize it maybe i'll lift a scar
or something you know that'd be really
cool
going back to the fish thing you know
yeah because both the fish has gone
through a lot i've gone through a lot
and we can just be like oh
minus exactly exactly
then i'll die of a heart attack and my
mammoths will leave me that's something
to look forward to
uh charles this was one of the most
amazing conversations i've ever had it's
truly an honor
that you would uh spend your valuable
time with me and
i'm glad you exist in the cryptocurrency
and the technology space and
i can see your love for mathematics and
your love for life just radiate
everything you do so thank you for being
you and thank you for talking to me
today it's a lot of fun thank you so
much lex
you